how much progress does a musician
make in 10 years well it's been
10 years since I last recorded the famous
piece gymnopedie number one by Eric Satie
and in this video I'm going to critique that old
performance tell you what I would do differently
today and then I'm going to record it again for
the first time in 10 years and you can tell me
which version do you prefer that video now has
over 1.8 million views which is amazing and this
may come as a shock but I hate this video
I honestly really want to take this video
down uh I don't like how I play in it I think
my technique and my sense of musicality and
interpretation has evolved over these 10 years I
hope but I feel the way I was playing back then
doesn't represent how I would play now and so it's
cringy to watch instead of taking it down though
I've decided that this could be a really great
opportunity using the last 10 years of my musical
development I'm going to now critique that video
and tell you what I would do differently today by
watching me critique my old self you can see that
a musician evolves over the years and perhaps you
can take the things I'm going to say and use
it to improve your own playing so here we go
let's start the video and start critiquing
my former self thank you foreign [Music]
the first thing I noticed is a look at this video
I didn't do too bad of a job considering it was
actually the very first time I ever attempted to
set up lights and a camera and film myself [Music]
so this is actually in my mom's basement she had
kind of like a photo studio set up with with some
lights and a camera so I just decided to take one
of the pieces I was practicing and do this video
and at various points in this video you can
actually hear birds chirping in the background
that's my mom's pet birds I'm about to really
criticize myself here but first I want to point
out that I do think what I'm doing here sounds
nice it's it's definitely pretty and there's a
lot of things especially for what I was doing at
the time that I think are nice this was very early
on in my classical playing I was really a rock
musician at this time and I just cut my hair and
was just getting into classical guitar so some
of these things I'm doing are pretty raw I think
foreign the first thing I'm hearing is that the
tempo can be too fast at times I sometimes rush
and sort of distort this beautiful slow ostinato
and ostinato is a repeating pattern throughout a
song in this case it's one two one two three
for me this pattern and the chords he uses
gives the impression of kind of slowly floating
through space [Music] it's very beautiful [Music]
that opening instantly puts you in sort of
a trance very meditative very mysterious but
I have the feeling on the recording
that I really didn't understand this
opening What I Hear 10 years ago
is something like this [Music] oh
in other words I'm bringing out
the top notes G sharp G sharp
but that's boring the top note stays the same the
whole time and is not really interesting instead
it was really interesting about this opening is
the part that changes what changes is the bass a
a for one the bass line but also and maybe more
importantly it's the inner voices that change
and I think are the most beautiful part of the
ostinato so we have a seashore [Applause] [Music]
and on top of that we have
e sure [Laughter] [Music]
and on top of all of that we have the
droning G [Music] El [Laughter] [Music]
so for me bringing out the inner voices is
actually the most beautiful thing at least that's
how I think now 10 years later going deeper what
I would do actually is lean on the first chord and
relax on the second chord lean on the first chord
and relax on the second chord almost like we're on
a boat we rock from right to left from right to
left and that's what creates that beautiful ebb
and flow of the piece that makes you feel like
you're kind of watching the water come in and
out on the shore if you'd like to learn gymnopity
on guitar or just improve your guitar playing in
general one of the best ways one of the fastest
ways is to get a one-on-one weekly teacher and my
wife and I have made an online music school called
rpajato.com to make it easier for you to find an
expert teacher these are colleagues and friends of
mine who I really trust and can take your playing
to the next level please check out rpajata.com
and while you're there check out all of our master
classes and workshops there's over 40 hours
of material there that you can watch that'll
make you a better musician use the code seti
s-a-t-i-e at checkout to get 25 off your first
pack of lessons back to the video another thing
I didn't realize and I actually remember this I
did not realize what key I was in the notes are
strange in this piece what chord is that there's
all these accidentals four sharps I knew where
to put my fingers and I used my intuition but I
didn't really understand the harmony I was playing
and therefore I think I missed quite a lot I wish
I could tell my former self the following four
sharps means we're in the key of E major so the
first chord which starts on an a can't be the
root position chord E major the one chord the
home base instead what we have is actually the IV
chord A major e f sharp G sharp a the four chord
is based on a so a major goes down to E major the
one chord so in other words the piece is a four
chord going to a one chord back to a four chord
going to a one chord the one chord is the point
of relaxation but so T is too eccentric and one of
them use it to be two maybe impressionist to be so
simple so he makes each one of those chords into
a Major Seventh chord this is a very Jazzy chord
very beautiful dream like chord
instead of the normal chord [Music]
the beautiful major seven you could
hear it a lot in jazz and in Bossa Nova
that sound so 10 years ago I didn't actually know
that and I think it led me just to kind of play
um nothing I just played simple thinking that
this is not interesting and what's interesting
is about to come but the austinetto pattern
by itself is the foundation of the piece and
I think I really I missed that Nuance at the
time so now [Music] keep this opening a bit
better and bring out those beautiful inner
voices let's listen to some more foreign
[Music]
I think I'm doing a good job here at actually
separating the Melody from the accompaniment so
the melody is the sort of the singing part that
if there were lyrics you could you could sing
that part and everything else is sort of the
the backup band right so In classical guitar
plan we often bring out the melody more than the
accompaniment and I'm doing that here but what
I notice is that the second I start the Melody
I speed up let's listen to that again [Music]
to hear how suddenly it gets faster I started
one two three one two I set up the meter one
two three and the second the melody starts
it sounds like one two three suddenly fast
and for me this destroys the beauty of
that moment which is the singer who is
singing on top of that beautiful foundation
in the first four measures so as you'll hear
in my new performance at the end of this
video I'm going to try to keep the pulse
steady while the melody enters hopefully I'm doing
it I think the reason I'm speeding up here is very
natural it's because I'm trying to crescendo I was
aiming here yeah [Music] and as a result I sped up
so when you Crescendo it's often easy to speed
up this is a trap you have to be careful [Music]
as we're listening I'm realizing another thing
I really failed to do 10 years ago was I never
actually looked up the original version for piano
real quick if you don't know anything about Eric
Satie he was a Pianist in the 19th century and he
was a pretty eccentric dude he was quite bizarre
he wrote pieces that were supposed to be repeated
at 840 times he only ate foods that were white in
color apparently he founded his own religion and
he encouraged his audience to actually ignore his
music and treat it as background ambient music
so gymnopity is actually a set of three pieces
that he composed in the late 19th century for
piano the title gymnopity seems to refer to
something about ancient Greek dancing some
type of festival and all he really writes is
which means slow and painful and he writes two
P's which means pianissimo very soft [Music]
originally for piano and being arranged for the
guitar it's so important everybody look up the
original version all you have to do is Google
the title of the piece and then imslp.org there
you'll find many versions of the piece for the
original instrument and arrangements and take a
look at the original version see what markings the
composer gives you it's so much good information
I have to admit that for me the cringiest
part of watching this video is how I move
of course how one moves when they play is up to
us you know it's preference and each person has
their own personality and style that's all fine
but the thing is I remembered at the time I was
new to classical music I was watching classical
performers and I saw them doing this type of thing
and I think at the time it wasn't always authentic
I think 50 of what I'm doing here is sort of
acting and that's what I really can't stand when
I watch this to be honest in the last 10 years a
lot of what I've been doing is figuring out what
is this thing that we're doing here why are we
playing this plucked instrument you know and and
making sounds out of it as Shakespeare said so
beautifully isn't it strange that sheep's guts
should hail Souls out of men's bodies sheep guts
being the the strings that were used historically
until the 1940s actually on guitars so he's
saying isn't it weird that we're taking sheep
intestines and putting it on wood and then people
are so moved when they listen to it to the point
of crying isn't that strange yeah that's weird
and as someone who spends their life trying to
play as beautifully as possible out of these
instruments and moving myself and others it's
completely natural to do some movement some
things require some movement to really play
well and I think we're kind of like actors as
performers we have to embody the affect or the
emotional content of the song I firmly believe
that and I try now to only do movements and
faces I don't think about them nothing I'm
doing is because I think people want to see this
if I move now it's because it just happens if I'm
making a face it's just what happens as a result
of trying to be emotional through my instrument
been 10 years ago I was doing that but something
else on top of it I think there was some extra
artificial movement and swaying going on that's
for me too much at least now maybe in 10 years
I'll hate what I'm doing now one thing I did kind
of intuitively on this recording is I kept that
one two three pattern going at the very end and
I went one two three one two three but in fact if
you look at the music it's really just one two
three one two three so I think today if I was
to do it again with that [__] was slowing down
to end the piece I would play one two three one
so here we go let's record the
whole thing and in the comments
please tell me which version did
you prefer 10 years ago or today
[Music]
thank you [Music] thank you [Music]
foreign [Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign [Music]
as you just heard this is how I feel about
the piece at this very moment but how am I
going to feel about this same piece in 10
more years perhaps I'll be making fun of
this version just as much as I did the last
one but that's okay this is what it means to
be an artist I believe as we mature as we
have life experiences as we work on music
our technique our conception we use all of that
to interpret what's on the page to be emotional
to tell a story and of course that changes over
time in fact maybe if I heard myself playing in
20 years right now maybe I wouldn't like it
but all that matters is at that point it's
the most beautiful thing to me thank you for
watching I have lots of resources out there
educational resources if you want to learn how
to improve your guitar playing the first is my
online music school rpajato that's a place where
you can have one-on-one lessons on Zoom with my
expert teachers these are colleagues friends of
mine who I think are fantastic and can help you
learn a plucked instrument then I have online
courses like classical tarpro.com where you
can do a self-paced course at home this course
takes you from a knowing nothing all the way to
playing recitals lastly if you want extra guitar
tips and want to support my YouTube channel the
best way is to check out my patreon like I said
they get lots of perks you can even have a lesson
with me and directly support the work that I
do thanks so much for watching don't forget to
leave a comment to tell me which version was your
favorite one and I'll see you next time [Music]
thank you
[Music]